i haven't been this star struck in a
long time
tika is a fashion mogul since december
it's been
insane loved it couldn't wear it when i
re-watched the video that we made i'm
like oh this is really cute i think it's
going to do well but i didn't realize
how big it would get
i had so many cute outfits planned for
this year that i couldn't wear so i just
wanted to show you
see this i love it i couldn't wear it i
think there was uh maybe
five or four days after it started going
viral it got shared
on the same day by jennifer aniston
justin bieber sharon stone
uh brook shields started following so i
was like okay this is this is big
hi tika i hear you're the new fashion
mogul
yes do you think you give me your
opinion i would like nothing more than
to help you priyanka thanks tika
grandpa chopra recently asked for
fashion advice from chica that video is
so funny
are you not even starstruck or are you
still constantly amazed with all the
attention from celebrities
no no it's it's not it hasn't sunk in
yet i think i'm still not realizing
what's happened back in december so it's
still going to take a while before it
sinks in what's really happening and how
how lucky we are to get to kind of do
all this
yeah i got boy problems
[Music]
our favorite so far has been lizzo
because not only did she repost tikka
in a matching outfit that lizzo had but
she also called tikka and i quote
a bed so that was just top notch
i mean after that you're good yeah i was
like where do we go from here
maybe a music video a music video with
lizzo that'd be next up
oh you've okay look you've put it out
into the universe it needs putting it
out there
now did i just see on social media that
you guys are expecting a baby this
spring
yes so me and my husband are expecting a
baby boy at the end of april
that is so exciting so look i have to
ask tika has been an only child for so
long how do you think she'll handle a
new baby in the house
you know we're not quite sure but we
have a few uh she has a few cousins
little cousins and she's realized that
they dropped free from a high chair
so i think she'll catch on that it could
be a good thing and if an ever-growing
fan base of celebrity followers and a
new baby
isn't enough to keep her busy tikka is
also taking to her instagram for series
commentary of pooch perfect episodes
airing tuesdays at 9pm eastern on
makeful tv
a tv show called pooch perfect reached
out to tika to help them promote the
show
so that was really fun because uh it's a
whole different side of the dog world
because wearing these clothes to keep
warm cause just having fur
release we're watching weekly we do
little recaps on our instagram
before each episode um so that's been
fun to kind of like be a part of it even
though we have nothing to do with the
dog grooming world
you